all right good morning everyone
thanks for coming to my all I defer at
two paws good morning everyone
and then okay that's about right yeah
it's a little lower to be talking about
DDD right
that's okay so just a little bit about
myself my name is Jimmy you can find me
on twitter @jrfromptc
[Music]
my journey with domain-driven design
over the past 10 or so years I had the
privilege or so I guess of working with
two very similar projects in the exact
same space said about three or four
years or parts and so part of this is
looking at all the bad things and wrong
things I did with domain urban design
and then I got to basically have a
do-over a few years later not rebuilding
the same system but a different one
where I got to kind of correct a lot of
the mistakes we found with the previous
one I don't often get that privilege
usually when I build a system I try to
build it for the long run and any
mistakes I make are pretty much in there
and I have to just wait for the next
project to correct them this was sort of
a unique situation where was a very very
similar domain and I got to just
basically have a do-over is pretty great
my my journey with domain driven design
started probably around 2005 or so I was
one of my first major products I was
working with and basically the existing
system was using things like type data
sets they were never used those things
they were amazing piece of technology
that lets you use designers against your
data now it's horrible and so that
reboot of that product we were looking
around like boys there's something we
can figure out how to belt better build
business oriented systems and domain
driven design seemed like a really good
choice for that so this is about ten or
so years ago now and throughout that
time from now until then we've had
well number of different systems I have
been put in production using domain
German design and so this talk is
basically trying to sum up my
experiences and my successes and
failures with DDD over the last 10 years
so let's look at the first system that
we were building this was what has now
turned him as a termed as a majestic
monolith has anyone heard this term
before
majestic monolith so this is a term from
the Ruby on Rails guys to describe a
Ruby on Rails system basically trying to
justify the kind of crazy code you
typically see in there to say it's not a
bad monolith it's one of the good
monoliths and we built in this system
this first system we built one of the
the bad kinds of monoliths we'll just
call it majestic because alliteration is
fun right this project started a year
before our company came on the previous
the previous vendor assigned to the
project spent a year just building
documents just writing documents
describing how the system is supposed to
work and have absolutely zero software
to show for it they spent a year just
doing Word documents and I think if if I
could describe a hell for myself it
would probably be a year writing word
documents of documentation and so
somehow they were able to do this of
building lots and lots of documents with
no software whatsoever to show for it
they fired that vendor and brought us
along to actually build something and
some of the interesting things about
this is one it was the first agile
project for any Texas government agency
this was a this was a system meant for
the entire state of Texas and no one men
had ever done any sort of agile project
before so that was a new one as well and
along with that because you know they
never done agile of course so they've
never done any sort of DDD either it's
so those two things put together meant a
lot of new things for this organization
the previous system oh I should describe
a little bit what this is all about so
this this this system was meant to
manage whenever a kid got in trouble you
got a and you're arrested there's a
legal process as you move through the
legal system
and those so the system we were building
it was all about kind of tracking the
progress of those cases throughout the
entire legal process and it was only
meant for miners not adults so they had
kind of different terms for things a
little politically correct so instead of
jail they call it a detention even
though it was a jail like there are bars
on doors and everything but they called
it attention and so it's really about
trying to build a system to manage those
those kids throughout that entire
process now the way the way city
governments work in the state of Texas
is every single jurisdiction has their
own IT budget and they all build their
own individual systems so what we wound
up having was in the previous system for
all the different cities in the state of
Texas each of them had their own
individual system about how to manage
this process the actual state
governments would have a set of laws
saying this is how the kind of the end
result should look like and then this is
how things work in the middle but the
actual kind of business process of how
things move throughout the system it was
up to each individual jurisdiction to
completely make up how that process
worked so we had a number of really
large constituencies like the city of
Dallas and the city of Fort Worth those
two cities are actually only about forty
kilometers or parts but they both have
populations well over well in the
millions but they have two very distinct
systems and now all the other large
cities in Texas had their own individual
system as well and to help with all the
small cities the state of Texas supplied
a kind of a pre-built kind of dummy down
system so that everyone else can use as
well so you had a number of this
different systems that all use kind of
the same terms the same legal terms but
internally how the process worked inside
each organization was completely
different
and I kind of draw a parallel to
something like e-commerce a lot of
companies I see sell stuff on the
internet when you get behind the scenes
the actual business practices that are
driving those driving and decisions and
driving the processes are all 100%
completely different and that's exactly
what we were running into the new system
to replace all these existing systems
would be it's an acronym of course
because it's a government
sort of thing would be the juvenile case
management system or as we called it
JCMs this new system was intended so
that every single constituent group
inside the state of Texas would use this
one single system and one of the one of
the big reasons for doing so is that one
there were actually there's no there
were no actually connections between
those previous systems so the kind of
real example we run into is a kid would
get arrested in Dallas and they had
family in Fort Worth so the kid would
moved to Fort Worth and they had no idea
that he had a criminal record over in
Dallas some of the worst examples are
things like they go cinamon to live with
an uncle and the Fort Worth documents
actually showed that there was abuse
coming from that uncle and we didn't we
had no idea none of the legal people had
any idea so there's an altruistic goal
here is to try to increase knowledge
sharing between all those different
groups because the the real goal of this
system was to not have the kid get in
any more trouble so most of the focus
was you know trying to have different
very social programs to help the family
and the kid not legal for the life of
crime and get them on the right path in
their life this system also cover every
single part of the process that the
juvenile could process will be touched
throughout the entire system and
actually a diagram of this and it's
intentionally hard to read this is a
this is a dumbed down version of the
legal process within each one there's
obviously lots of different business
processes so yet something like here
that would say something like grand jury
which is just a piece of text on this
the actual grand jury process in the
state of Texas is insanely complicated
we went to one group to see how they
scheduled this this process which is
basically you have to schedule the court
hearing amongst a bunch of other court
hearings and what that lady would do
would she put physically all the case
documents on the ground and physically
arranged them to figure out how to best
arrange everything because you had
things like an indigent defense attorney
which is a defense attorney provided by
the state and
you want to have to make that person
come back and forth from their office so
they would try to arrange it by that or
you'd see this kid had multiple counts
or perhaps he gotten there was like he
was in some certain gang and then
there's another gang that was on the
same day so let's add them under like
just all these crazy rules I had in
their head
it's just represented by this one little
piece of text on this diagram up here
well our system was meant to handle all
of this picture and it was a very very
very big picture so we started the
project just you know bright-eyed and
bushy-tailed saying you know we're gonna
be the first great agile project in the
state of Texas and the first great
Dedede project so what do what is one of
the first thing you do on an agile
project besides writes a year's worth of
documentation yes
yeah motivational posters or
demotivational something like that so
the very first thing we did was create
personas agile personas this was kind of
a big thing this project started about
two thousand seven or eight or so so
that's one of the big things you heard
back then is you had to create personas
for the different kinds of users that
would be using your system so we went
through this process of creating all
these different personas I also couldn't
fit them all on the screen because you
couldn't read it now these are just a
few of the samples of them I got about
let's see what 24 on this one there were
72 total personas that were going to be
using this system and now this is the
point where we should have seen maybe
this system was going to be too big but
no we were gonna drive on we were gonna
we were gonna make this make this system
part of it part of the reason as well as
when you're consulting sometimes you can
only push back with the clients so much
before they fire you so this is another
one whose areas like maybe we should
have more than one system and they said
maybe you should shut up and just build
it like this like okay thanks well we'll
do that then so the the behind the
scenes we'd have a lot of conversations
about trying to figure out all these
different kind of groups in the system
and security was defined based on these
as well each one of these each one of
these personas represented typically
either one or a group of people inside
an actual county we also had
sometimes specific counties some of the
smaller counties in the state of Texas
this like all this entire box might be
just like three people but in other
bigger counties like in Dallas for
example they might have a staff in the
hundreds of people that were performing
all this personas so for someone like
that this picture made a lot of sense
but for a smaller group it didn't make
any sense whatsoever but again because
we were building one system for everyone
we had to make a few compromises like
that now when you have 72 of a thing
that's just too many to reason about so
what we had to do was start to color
code these different personas these
personas were actually I wish had to
picture this they sell these giant
post-it notes they're like this big and
we use those post-it notes and put them
on the wall of all these different
personas this was like literally a whole
wall that was filled with all these
different things and we want to having
to buy different colors of these to try
to color code the different personas in
the system so we we color-coded them
based on the different state agencies I
only have like four colors here but
they're why not being about twelve
different colors in the end of all these
different colors of these different
agencies so this again should have been
the first sort of key in our brains that
if I'm having if I'm having to group
different users in the system based on
different kind of roles and
responsibilities and having these major
areas maybe again this is too many
people using this exact same system so
that was our first lesson that's that
chapter at the end of the book of the
mode domain is it one actually written
read the domain driven design book okay
who was actually read it okay okay
there's also the ddd quickly book which
again focuses on a lot of the things
that aren't as important and skips the
part of the end evans Eric Evans
actually did a podcast a couple years
ago that was something like DDD ten
years later and one of the things he
described was if he had to do the book
over again he would have taken basically
the beginning first one or two sections
and cut that down to like ten pages and
put it as an appendix and take the part
on bounded context and try to make that
basically the gist of the entire book
and that was one of the big things that
we learned from this project is that
the bounded contacts are probably the
most important parts of domain-driven
design and the other stuff is just kind
of intellectual yak shaving sort of
thing yak shaving bike shedding yak bike
shaving something that we do we just
argued endlessly about so the picture I
have here is actually the picture from
the production system and each of those
menu items is a separate state agency
that is dedicated to that thing and so
once she got inside of that that's when
you had like okay here's the actual
system meant for this individual person
I don't know what half of them actually
mean and it turns out the the product
owners didn't know what half of them
meant and any either because there's not
any one person that has the entire legal
system of the state of Texas in their
head so we had to pull and pick
different people for these different
areas so no one actually knew how
everything actually fit together
but there was one domain model that
everything came from in fact the central
domain model of the system which was
juvenile like you had to scroll down for
all of the different collection
associations that were on this
individual entity because every one of
these things was again a collection of
things associated with it it was
absolutely maddening so that was our
very first lesson that if you're going
to do DDD you should probably do a
little bit of research on what those
bounded contexts should be we did not we
skipped it and just did one single bound
in context for the entire thing another
area where the cracks began to show were
around some models in our system
especially when we had names of things
that didn't mean anything to anyone but
we had to find some common language that
everyone could share so this is the
concept of the ubiquitous language and
when we have dozens of state agencies
across the state of Texas if you try to
have the term of a thing try to be
shared across all those different groups
you're just going to be giving yourself
a headache because no one's gonna agree
on exactly what one term meant and so
what wound up being happening in our
system is we had to invent very very
generic terms things like a person well
there's no definition of a person and
the legal
system of Texas so this thing that was
very central nervous system a person
actually had no analog and the actual
domain of anyone's individual system but
it's what we had to do one of the other
things the system was trying to do was
was this idea of having one source of
truth for basically the world and so if
you have the source of truth for the
world you have to have entities like
person because you can't duplicate data
across any amount of context there's got
to be a single person that goes off the
entire lifetime of the system and so
that's what we had here is a person a
person no one actually could describe
what this thing was I don't know when
other than it represented a person in
the real world but what I meant in terms
of the legal system never really had any
meaning whatsoever so that was their
next big lesson in the system is that
ubiquitous language should actually be
ubiquitous and maybe if you don't know
what that word means go look it up and
they come back and see if that actually
corresponds to the things you're
actually using in your system now when
we have all these different government
agencies one of the things that
government agencies really do well is
work well with each other right no not
at all
so these dozens and dozens of different
agencies we had a few main ones first
was the law enforcement agency this is
the people that actually be the
arresting officers we had the the
prosecutors they would they would try
the cases against the kids and then we'd
have the court system that would how you
know mandate they would oversee the
legal process and finally the probation
department that's the juvenile probation
department this this JPD people these
are the ones who are actually trying to
help the kids no one else gave two flips
at all I like the the cops were just
like we're just out here it's about to
maybe we can't really a bad joke but I
shouldn't do that
filtered on sorry it's it's early enough
to my filters actually still working so
that's good so the the le a folks they
were just they're just out there
responding to calls and processing
arrests that's really what they're doing
on a daily basis trying to protect and
serve allegedly and they're they're
really they honestly some of us they
don't even know if it's if it's kid or
not because they just see someone
getting in a fight they don't have
identification so they get arrested they
take him to jail
and it's through processing than
actually learned Oh actually he's
fifteen years old so we actually need to
go through this other specific process
so when we looked at we went to these
different groups and said what is what
is the thing you're doing kind of island
on a daily basis what's the what's the
kind of most important thing in your
life as whatever you're doing so the law
enforcement people said the offense and
the arrests that is what we're measured
on that is what we reports to the
state's everything revolves around
someone doing something wrong and us
arresting for them us arresting them for
it
of course of course is all about the
trial there they're two mandates and
oversee the legal process and again they
don't really care about what exactly is
happening they're just there to really
follow the letter of the law
the prosecution office is really about
cases they're about managing a flow of a
case through a system either getting it
to trial and getting some sort of
outcome or maybe having some sort of
plea agreement or dropping the case
entirely but cases are the most
important thing and finally JPD those
are the people that were always asking
the question but what about the children
what about the children that was just
them so again a thing that we should
have noticed is if we're asking each of
these people what is the most important
core part of your daily work and they
all have completely wildly different
answers that maybe we should go back and
look at that bounded context thing again
but no driving on building the system
like it is anyway so bounded context
have this concept of a core domain and
that was our next lesson that if you are
going to ask all the people in the
system what the core domain is what the
core purposes of the system they should
all have the same answer
and they don't have the same answer then
you probably need different systems
because all those different groups are
gonna have very competing concerns about
those boundary points between those two
those two those different boxes so going
on we asked the different people like
what what does what does say it's a
juvenile represent in your system like
what what does that thing represent the
juvenile model object we had in her
system so I should say we had the person
thing we also had a subclass which was a
juvenile so we went through an a school
what does that represent to you what
does this jubilant represent well law
enforcement said form CR - 23 J it was
like a scene from the movie Brazil
literally so then for them they didn't
really care about it being a kid or not
it was just this specific form that are
presented in offense and arrest and that
was all what they were about I mean when
you hear like we see like peace police
procedural shows were there not doing
paperwork half the time it's a dirty lie
because if they do nothing but basically
fill out paperwork all the time of all
these different things that are
happening and that was one of the major
pieces of paperwork they had was to fill
out the details of an offense and an
arrest so for them there was no such
thing as a juvenile there was just a
form they filled out that described the
incident that happened and what the
outcome was on the court side a jewel
little case was just something to
adjudicate it was really nothing else
they didn't they didn't really care much
about the details it was just again to
try to follow some legal procedure on
the prosecution side this was an offense
with something to charge for and that
contrasted directly with the probation
department which was an offense being
something he wanted to move past so
while the prosecution wanted to like get
get successful get successfully charged
and convict the kids the probation
department had the exact opposite where
they wanted to drop the charges so
wasn't on the permanent record and try
to get down a better path in life this
is also this this this conflict back and
forth is something that's I'll talk I'll
talk
little bit later when we act we actually
talked to the prosecutors Education
Department's about the system and how
much they hated us for this conflict we
put in there so in addition to a
ubiquitous language needing to be
ubiquitous the other thing we needed to
have is consensus about a specific term
so on the that illustration was the term
offense and juvenile if I asked every
single group what that term even meant
they all had different definitions of
that term and again if people can't
agree on what a term means then it
probably have to have some sort of
division of those contexts now I have
run into cases in which I have something
that in the industry there hasn't been a
decision on a sort of ubiquitous term
for something and so sometimes I do have
to work with my product owners to help
drive a consensus to say okay you're
saying this word you're saying that word
it sounds like those mean the same thing
can you just use the same word so you're
not confusing everyone and then like a
year later or finally six and they start
using the same word and it's actually
something I have to practice myself like
I will subtly like correct them not in
you know not out you know overtly
correct them but sort of subtly if they
use the wrong word I'll repeat it back
but using the correct word without
saying something like well actually or
something like that so you're dumb it's
okay if your domain does not have a
ubiquitous language it can sense this
around something but you should be able
to drive towards it and if you can't
drive towards it because the word has so
many different meanings across your
different groups that are using it then
again you don't have one system you have
many systems now the last piece is
something I found that was kind of
unique to the domain driven design
community that most people are really
interested in talking about the patterns
of domain driven design instead of those
chapters at the end and so this this
right here is actually a picture of one
of the repositories in my system you can
also see there's no there's no closing
curly brace because it continues on down
towards the floor and then over here
probably up the aisle a little bit as
well
so there's a there's a few there's a few
competing patterns for the repository
pattern out there we use both of them in
our system because it started during the
time period with one pair one pattern
was popular and then continued on to
where the other pattern became popular
so we won I'm just using both and so we
spent a lot of time trying to figure out
what is the best what is the right
pattern for an entity what is the right
pattern for a value object what about
those aggregates how are we going to
distinguish in our object model between
aggregates and just other kinds of
entities and repositories don't even get
me started about repositories let's make
sure those are just right so our system
just really try to focus on getting the
patterns the way they're supposed to be
implemented as opposed to kind of taking
a step back and looking at well you know
barring any of those kind of patterns
that we that we see there what is the
what is the right way to model this kind
of system so if I had to do this part
over again I would not focus on the
structural patterns at all in fact those
are the kind of things that are pretty
easy to refactor towards so in my
systems I would just I would just avoid
putting any of those patterns in place
at the beginning and wait for the code
to kind of tell me that those patterns
are necessary I need to put them in
place we we had a few of those in the
book they DDD big the DDD book they call
the the read the refactoring
breakthroughs and we had a couple of
those where we'd have a Friday email is
saying okay everyone check in their code
because we're gonna have this
refactoring over the weekend and come
back and Monday morning and everything
is going to be changed so it turns out
that the the structural patterns we put
in place prevented us from making those
refactoring changes that would have
provided a much deeper insight into our
system because those structural patterns
really kind of hardened and ossify and
solidify how you use your code and if we
were able to get rid of them we would
have much better ability to make those
kind of deeper refactorings in our
system not to mention just the just
endless arguments about the right kind
of repository that we write kind of
entity none of our customers cared about
that's like having a better repository
was not going to provide a better user
experience
or like prevent a kid from getting in
trouble so it was just a complete waste
of time so what are the system in-depth
I would still consider it a success
because it's in production today and
it's being used across the entire state
of Texas but it's a very very large
system and not everyone is happy with it
but their captive audience they have to
use it so Matt it is a very very large
system the final tally and I just pulled
this like a few weeks ago because it's
still being actively developed and added
and features that on to 195 controllers
652 actions 121 different security roles
in the system this is because cities
like Dallas have a lot of different
people and I just feel really bad for
those like small East Texas towns that
have to configure 120 roles to be like
Sheila so sorry Sheila 218 different
entities in this system
184 value objects 352 in it numeration
's but we deploy to about 50 counties in
the state of Texas at this point and
there's about 250 so about 20 percent of
the counties and about 80 percent of the
population of the state of Texas is
going through the system there are a
couple rules in there like if last name
is Bogart then go ahead and just go
ahead and you know drop the case but
those are some Easter eggs so I'm gonna
have a system that's bigger than this in
terms of controllers and actions
okay I've asked a few people that and
they're all like no and we shouldn't
that's not something to be proud of
actually we were proud of this we we
actually had meetings with a with the
asp.net MVC team whitfill hack come down
to her office
we're like showing him this like look
how big this is like the biggest MVC app
that you have ever seen he's like yeah
and then looking back he had this like
look in his eye like like we were crazy
but now I know yes indeed he was he was
right yeah so I haven't actually met
anyone that's built a system bigger this
nor anyone crazier than us to build a
system bigger than this but I still
again call it a success just because I
went to production and I've worked with
so many teams that have projects usually
they build project Phoenix that never go
to production so I don't feel too bad
that ours actually made a production
so the picture that is usually drawn by
the majestic model of people looks
something like this
you're the slowly futuristic city
everything's nice and clean and there's
floating roads because those things are
really easy to build and no one ever
needs to change with the directions and
places where those things are but in the
reality it's more like district 9 sort
of city where it's just a complete mess
and like aliens are eating cat food and
that sort of thing just all over the
place so that was about three or four
years of my career building that system
and then we get a call about a year
after we were done with that project
that's we get to get a do-over
so we didn't get to replace the existing
system and fix those wrongs because you
really shouldn't do that anyway like
just rewrite a system because don't you
don't like the code what we did have
though is an opportunity to help build
the adult version of this system so we
built the kids version that has their
own sort of legal process and now we're
we're going to be building the adult
system well it turns out that the group
that originally contracted with us they
build the juvenile system actually tried
to build the adult system the exact same
way and failed with someone else and so
they came in to call us to say okay
we're not gonna try to build the entire
system not because it's wrong because
but because we don't have the money for
it anymore
we wasted on the other one but we only
have enough money for this one little
part and then it turned out to be a
great great big win for us because we
don't have to worry about fighting them
over let's not build a ginormous single
monolith let's just build one a little
piece and do that one really well so
this projects was way too costly
expensive risky to build a single system
and instead of trying to build one
system for absolutely everyone in the
world we were just going to be focusing
on a single agency at a time and the
agency we're going to start with
actually had the most money in that
state of Texas because believe it or not
they actually care about prosecuting
people more than anything else in Texas
like right right below guns is
convicting people so those are the
people that had the most money and
that's who we're going to start with so
in that original diagram that meant that
the people that were worried about did
you notice this was color coded as well
so like people before us had already
figured out like don't don't
try to put everything under one umbrella
and so we just had this one section
right here that was dealing with
prosecution and those prosecution
services down here this is the juvenile
section so the juvenile section with
those hundreds of controllers that was
only this little sliver right down here
so like trying to get a single system
for the rest of the adult system would
have been absolutely absolutely
impossible so this new system because we
learned her lesson and also because they
didn't have the money to try to build
the entire system we had to build a
system around bounded contexts so we had
a bounded context around a prosecution
agency and inside the prosecution
Department that's when you had really
good names for things in fact when you
go and ask like the prosecution
Department what is the most important
thing in your system is it is it the
defendant no is it the what's the
opposite of the defendant the plaintiff
thank you I need to watch more law and
order procedural shows that sort of
thing
yeah so is it the plaintiff no so what
is the most important thing it's
actually the case not the person
involved with the thing it's the actual
case itself that is a thing that
actually moves through the system a case
represents potentially multiple offenses
multiple defendants multiple plaintiffs
multiple offenses multiple incidents
multiple arrests these this one folder
physical folder for some of these cases
represents the thing that moves through
the system for that group now outside of
this prosecution agency if you talk to
what the law enforcement agency courts
or some of these other people like what
about what does a case mean to you
they're like what case I don't care
that's just something my prosecution
buddy tells me over beers but there's no
such thing as a case in my system
probably law enforcement we just have
arrests and we hand the arrests of the
prosecutors and they take him from there
as part of our as part of this effort to
we wouldn't talked to the different
prosecution agencies I was kind of
interesting because some of the
prosecution agencies and the prosecutors
used the juvenile system and at the time
we hadn't quite understood what we had
put on people with a single majestic
monolith and so we asked a couple
prosecutors Oh what we were the people
behind the juvenile system what do you
think of that like literal quote little
quotes and that was a little bit of a
little bit of a shock you know as the as
the I was the tech lead at the previous
system as well to hear people like use
foul language for something I built and
was so very proud of and actually wrote
you know dozens and dozens of blog posts
about that system a necessary or someone
like oh that piece of [ __ ]
oops so in this new system the previous
system was all about the kids but if you
remember all your prosecutors don't care
about the kids they care about the case
going through the system so that meant
the view of the new system was all
centered around a case and in fact the
previous system when you'd actually do
do anything the system and actually to
start with the juvenile so the
prosecutors whenever they wanted to
manage their cases in the system they
had to remember like what was the name
of that kid that this case was about all
I got a search for that first oh well
then it pulls up the kid then it goes a
little drop-down list and it goes
prosecutor and then the prosecution that
section there's a Stafford cases I
cooked the cases tab and there's a case
to entry ahead click the elders in my
case now I got to it and the new system
cases were front front and center in
this system so everything was about how
they manage cases and what status they
were in and how they move through the
system the what did I get in trouble
here for burglary of a rail car by the
way don't steal rail cars in Texas that
is actually a felony there so just word
of warning so the the concept of a case
because we were able to focus just on
that core domain of that prosecution
agency meant that the overall system the
domain the interactions could be much
richer because they were able to focus
just on that single just on a single
bout in context so this was the first
lesson we learned from the contrast of
the previous one is when we have a Co
very cohesive bounded context that
actually brought us a lot of clarity
into how the prosecution agency works to
have even deeper inside to how to make
their lives better make their jobs
easier the reason why the prosecutor
called our system a piece of crap before
is because it wasn't built for him
was built for the probation department
the probation department does no idea
what the prosecutors are doing and in
fact there's quite a bit of an
adversarial relationship whereas the
stories that the probation department
told us were about how the kids lies
they've stayed on the prosecution side
that they remember all their really bad
cases and so there when I was able to
say oh we helped this so-and-so kid and
he's able to come back with like and
some other kid like killed his whole
family were like oh like fade into the
background let's change the subject here
we also to be very careful about the
dummy data we put in the system so
things like Bart Simpson killed Maggie
Simpson and did something with Homer
Simpson they would remember a case that
was just like that so like okay we'll
just
we're just burgle a bunch of rail cars
let's just do that because that's no one
no one gets unhappy about that now the
next piece we had was specifically
around the roles and security in the
system in the previous application we
actually made all of the personas the
agile personas and two roles in the
system and admits that they had to
configure 120 different roles no matter
where they deployed this application and
the next version of the system we model
or you our roles and security quite a
bit different what we made was all the
permissions in the system were
hard-coded and that was because you
couldn't just invent new actions that
you could do or new tasks that you could
do so we had a hard-coded list of all
the things you can do in the system but
past that it was 100% dynamic so we'd
have a table for the roles that would
tie roles to different users and if you
wanted to have different privileges you
assign that person different roles and
if you're some small East Texas County
where you slip a 50 underneath the desk
to get out of something then you can
just have one role in your system which
is like you know Boss Hogg sheriff or
something like that I don't know and
then that person can have all the
permissions associated with that system
and what we did make hard-coded though
we're all of the permissions the
permissions that our system were also
very task-oriented as well that meant
that
every single permission correspondent to
an individual an individual activity
that someone could perform and then
finally when we went to enforcing the
permissions we would enforce them just
feed us this kind of attribute we
decorate on controllers the previous
system used role based authorization
which I cannot stress enough never do
role based authorization gives you no
flexibility on how to associate those
activities that people do to the roles
so we'd have roles in the system there
was something like okay this is a Betty
the bartender because bartenders are no
bartenders aren't users in the system
Larry the law enforcement agents but in
some counties Larry the law enforcement
agent actually was able to do this other
thing over here so we'd have to invent
new roles or like Larry the law
enforcement agent they can also do this
other thing except not that other thing
because this other person complained so
instead of trying to force security
throw those roles we enforce them all
through individual permissions the other
really cool thing we did with this is
anytime you had a link on the page it
would check the controller action to see
does this person have permission to do
that activity they didn't permission to
do that activity the link wouldn't even
show up for them so enforced it when
they actually executed the action and
then we also enforced it in the system
so that's when we wouldn't even allow
them to see things and do things and
they didn't have the political
privileges to do so so with a previous
system that had to be built for everyone
in the state of Texas I had to have this
sort of infinite flexibility in some
areas and then super super rigid in some
areas so what a focused system allowed
us to do is to be able to be flexible in
the places we needed to and rigid and
the others where we wanted to have some
commonality across the system we could
only really do this though if we were to
have that like laser focus on a single
bounded context the next one was a fun
one the file management problem so we
went to two different I went to a number
of different county agencies but I went
to the Dallas County agency the Dallas
prosecution not department
and went to the Fort Worth prosecution
department and even though the cities
are like 40 kilometers or parts and you
think would share a lot of information
they're actually in different Texas
counties in the state of Texas which
means they have completely different IT
budgets departments like they don't
really actually they kind of hate each
other because the forward people are
kind of hipster Dallas is like kind of
big city they each think they're better
than the other so what was interesting
is when we went to both departments and
asked them what is the number one
problem that you're running into that
you want our system to solve and they
both have the exact same answer we have
a file management problem great that's
great we have some consensus on
something let's solve that problem we
talked to the the the Fort Worth County
Prosecutor's Department and it said okay
can you tell me a little bit more about
your file management problem well it
said their file management problem is
they've got too much data and one of the
things they were doing very recently was
having these police cars have the
dashboard cameras on them to record
incidents with a handy delete button in
case there was something like you didn't
want anyone to see and these the this
digital media would be submitted as part
of the digital as part of the evidence
so you could actually see if someone got
arrested or something you'd have some
sort of video evidence then also pull
things from CCTV as well for you know
convenience stores or the robbery they
can pull that in as well
and they just piled up over time so
their biggest problem was we've got just
so much data
there's archival there's archival laws
that say we have to keep this data for
like 20 years and so we're just seeing
this grow and grow and grow because as
we get more and more digital the the
world gets more and more digital a lot
of the evidence becomes more and more
digital as well and there's also laws
that you can't compress things as well
so they'd have to have in the most RAW
format possible because again there's a
specific evidence law for that it's like
oh that's a pretty cool problem to try
to solve that you've got so much data
that you have to worry about trying to
figure out how to how to store it an
archive of it and be able to pull it up
efficiently now going to the Dallas side
of things who also said data file
management problem this was their file
management problem a leaky roof
so their files were still paper-based
this was 2014 2013 and they still had
100 100% paper-based system now the
Dallas Metroplex is something like 6 or
7 million people and boggling I just
boggle the mind that in order to process
all that they were so going through
paper-based documents to manage the
entire process and when you have a leaky
roof it can ruin your cases literally
they would have times there when we'd
walk in and be like by sheer panic going
around everyone's just like buzzing
around like bees or something and we've
like what's going on today oh we lost a
case oh I mean don't you lose cases on a
daily basis like no we lost it we can't
find it they're going around like des -
des like tits did did jonah take it over
there no no no III definitely put it
back over there and if they physically
lost a case it would have to be
dismissed because that was like that was
everything was in that there's no copies
as that was it so yeah if they if I go a
leaky roof or someone loses the kid
physically loses a case that actually
loses the case for them in real life and
they had stories of that where they've
lost I actually lost cases so the amount
of procedures they had in place to like
lock that you know check out the case
put your time down that you checked it
out if you if someone will come at the
end of the day look through like who has
not checked out a case or checked it
back in yet did you check that home it's
not you can't take it home because then
who knows who can get access to it so
just kind of funny to think they had the
same exact problem but actually two
totally different ways of working it so
this is the kind of thing way to deal
with where we're trying to build a
system that's going to work for both
kinds of groups one group that is
heavily processed oriented and one is
just heavily digital oriented how do you
can you build a system with workflows
that is trying to manage both of those
different processes this is one of the
big complaints we had with the previous
system because we're trying to build a
system for everyone it was impossible
for us to get consensus about how the
system should work so we'd wind up doing
is saying guys we're at a time we just
got a you know we got to build something
so let's just do this workflow and then
you can tell us how it's wrong submit a
bug report whatever
that was one of the reasons they all
hated us is because we forced their
agencies and do very specific workflows
that did not work for them whatsoever so
in the new system we needed to build a
flexible workflow that can work for both
of these kinds of agencies now yes we
would digitize these people over there
but again they're so far behind the
curve in kind of IT there's the like
late adopter laggard and they're like
way off the end like what's an what's an
IT department sort of thing so we had a
build a system they can handle both of
these kinds of customers so we wound up
doing is building a system that had
flexible workflows in the system so each
individual agency could have whatever
kind of workflow they wanted to in order
to move cases through the system and we
wouldn't tell them or dictate them how
that process should work so this case we
had specifics we had dynamic statuses
for where that case could be because
while one county could say this is my
business process for a case going
through our internal agency and another
one say actually we just go straight
from the we don't have that person
between the engineer and the customer we
just take the information directly from
them they can drive that workflow
however they wanted to we would have
transitions defining a begin state and
in state and this is just a state
machine right that's all we're trying to
build here and the last thing we did was
we tied security to those transitions as
well so that only specific roles could
potentially do specific kinds of
transitions so not everyone can just
dismiss a case has to be like the chief
prosecutor or whatever they'd have in
there that could do that sort of
activity and because we still need to
have some knowledge of like the base
actions we would still tie them into
kind of a named action as well so if as
a if it was a transition that
represented a very specific thing in the
legal process we could have that in
there as well and finally when some of
the prosecution agencies need to have
something very custom associated with it
we'd include different actions
associated with it so they could have
like this action needs to go to this
custom page - as that has these fields
on it because when they approve a case
for submission they need to gather some
additional information so we were able
to pull that in as well
the next piece we did with those Triffid
transitions is that we drove all the
work via these cues and this actually
very well solidified in their head when
we into the paper-based agency they
actually had physical stacks of cases on
people's desks that represented where
that case was in the different processes
and so what we want them doing is
modeling that exact sort of domain and
that was the exact processes in our
system so beyond just the kind of the
the legal model that we needed to model
so the case and offenses arrest we also
needed to have a model for how their
business process worked now none of none
of that model actually existed it was
just how they got stuff done but we
needed to have some sort of model for
that in our system as well so that was
our let that was our next lesson is that
sometimes the model needs a model so
that I can so that I can model the model
as it goes through this as it goes
through the system so not every net
every organization has this sort of
issue where they have very dynamic
workflows and it's something I'm really
hesitant to put in place because I
usually try to push I try to push the
group's I work with to say you really
need to figure out what your business
process is and not just have kind of
random things if you don't have a
defined business process that's where
you have like like every entity has like
a note section or comments section and
that comment section is actually where
the business process occurs does anyone
have a comments section with like dates
and names and like what so yeah your
business processes he actually the note
so we wanted to take that and build a
model on top of that so that we could
actually enforce a business process
through the system now on one thing very
controversial at the time anyway I hope
I've blogged and spoke about it enough
that it's not as controversial then one
of the first things I did was ditch all
of those structural patterns from the
get-go my basic philosophy was I will
not introduce any sort of pattern or any
sort of structure into my system until
the code tells me that it's needed and
the code telling me that is needed is I
don't know kind of like a horse
whisperer kind of thing like the code
has to speak to you somehow but you can
got to just use the basic code smells
from the old Fowler refactoring book as
sort of a guide
to say these are the things I'm seeing
in my code what can i refactor towards
to help encapsulate those patterns now
one of the things we had in our system
was the idea of having having requests
and responses being as if being the
thing that we modeled in their system so
our original repository with those 80
different methods on it each one of
those methods is only ever used in one
spot in the system but when actually
went to the repository had everything
every kind of data access thing ever
that's why you had that explosion of
methods in there because every single
new kind of query that we had to do we
had to create yet another method on
there or just expose out aquaria Bowl
and just say you know f it you know here
you go
do whatever you want so when we went to
this new process I did not introduce any
sort of pattern until as actually kind
of emerged throughout the system and the
pattern we kind of landed on was the
CQRS style application where our
requests and responses were modeled
explicitly as individual objects and
then we would have the the request
handlers be the actual business logic
behind the scenes
well this meant was we didn't have a
single repository or a service helper
manager object in her system the
business logic for individual activities
would always reside in these individual
handlers for a specific kind of request
so in this case I'm handling a specific
request to show this is an index action
to show I try to pull one of the simple
ones this is to show the aliases
associated with a person on a case so it
makes a query does a list does some
autumn up for projection because I was a
tech lead and that's how I roll and
returns that view model to the end user
now how we're crazy
this query would get it would be 100%
encapsulated behind this single class in
fact if we needed to drop down into raw
sequel because performance reasons or
whatever that's okay because it doesn't
affect the rest of my application when I
had a repository has that single
interface that everyone used they meant
that I couldn't easily switch that thing
out for something else because if I
switched it out in one spot I have to
switch out in every single spot
in this class I have no abstractions
whatsoever I've got a reel and this guy
says using in hibernate a real and
hibernate container or a session and a
real this is a structure map I think a
real dependency injection container no
abstractions no nothing like that just
use the raw thing as much as possible
and if this needs to change then I only
have this one single spot where I need
to go fix that and we had those cases
come up we had some pages that this the
the trying to go through the domain
model to do my sort of querying that I
need to was impossible so we just
dropped down and used something like pet
apoco or in poco those micro ORM things
where you just using sequel we can just
use that in here instead or we can use
and however they actually let you do raw
sequel as well but it doesn't perform
quite as well as the in poco stuff so we
were able to do that and that one
specific spot and didn't affect the rest
of our application so that was the next
lesson we had was to not follow not
blindly follow any sort of pattern
advice I often get questions asked like
is there can I build out a reference
Dedede application and the answer is
almost always no actually the answer is
always no and the reason being is that
when you see a DDD application you're
seeing the end result of hundreds of
different conversations and decisions
made up at to that point and there's a
lot of assumptions that people have been
making and a lot of things that've been
verified that if you get to the end and
just say that's how we should do it
you're missing out on the important part
which is really the journey of how they
actually got there so when I see when I
see DDD reference applications they're
usually way too simple for me to even
say why would you even use all this
structure it's just way too much work or
I miss so much conversation that I'm
having arguments with myself like well I
should have done it this way well I
wasn't in the room when they made that
decision I don't understand the
constraints they were under so I can't
just blindly put all these sort of
patterns and practices in place I have
to let the journey of the project tell
me where I need to go now when you build
a system it has to that when you build a
system that is not a single monolithic
system with a single database you know
introduced a new problem which is how to
deal with others whenever I have now one
now one system that has to talk to
multiple systems now got to worry about
integration this is one of the reasons
why people typically don't try to go
down these SOA Micra service bound a
context route is because integration is
actually really really hard and it's
even harder when I'm talking about
dealing with other government agencies
that very often do not really like each
other the law enforcement agents and the
prosecution agency really love each
other
I think if we saw that a lot like you
can shoot and kill someone as a cop and
you probably are going to get prosecuted
for it
that kind of buddy-buddy in relationship
with other ones they do have not so good
a relationship like the indigent defense
the the defense attorneys that are doing
pro bono they're representing clients on
the behalf of the state there's not a
very good relationship between these two
people like they don't go to the same
bars that kind of thing and so but we
had to have a system that could allow
each of these different people to talk
to it so we built based on each
individual use case different kinds of
interactions different integrations
based on those specific how how closely
those two agencies work together in real
life for example the law enforcement
agency in prosecution department beyond
just being buddy-buddy in real life
there's actually a very strong
relationship between those agencies in
the legal system so what we want to
doing is building a very special portal
for the law enforcement agencies to come
up they believe like come up to kiosks
in the prosecution department and with
their arrest reports in hand they be
able to just look at them and type them
in as quickly as possible so on the
prosecution agency side we've made
things very lovely looking and you know
user experience out the wazoo all that
sort of thing the police the police
tomorrow didn't care about that all they
cared about was coming in topping their
stuff as fast as possible and leaving so
that's when we did have a giant forum
with a you know a hundred different
fields on it because that was the best
thing for them but we can only do that
if we talked to them and said okay what
is the most important thing when you're
just doing this interaction with the
prosecution department we're not trying
to replace your hole in law enforcement
system just this one interaction what is
the most important thing and they said
to get in and out as fast as possible we
don't like typing we re already we
already wrote this stuff once what are
we gonna write it again can I just give
this to a law clerk and they'll type it
up and law clerks like no you type it up
so we wanted to try to speed that
process much as possible something like
the defense attorney side this is really
interesting because there's a there's a
lot of legal restrictions about what the
defense attorneys can actually see in
the prosecution system there's certain
discovery I don't know that's a word
I've heard on law and order again
there's certain laws that dictate what
kind of information they're allowed to
look at so in that case we wind up being
building a completely separate system
that used a rest hypermedia API actually
hypermedia and that portal then
communicated it was very very blocked
about what kind of information they can
see just based on them big a defense
attorney whereas the le.a they can have
access to quite a bit more stuff because
they might be a lot of communication hey
did you have evidence for this oh here
it is let me go ahead and upload it this
was a very very pinched portal so that
was our final lesson that micro services
and any corruption leaders are your
friend especially when you have two
especially we have to have integration
between different bonded context that
what you can help solve these problems
are building any corruption layers and
then going back and and really trying to
drive towards this micro service concept
so that each individual group can have
their own system that conforms to their
own individual rules final tally of this
system now it is a it was a very large
system but I would say it only dealt
with the prosecution agencies so I
didn't feel too terribly bad it had 70
controllers down from close to 200 or so
before 600 actions seems like a lot but
we had like way more Ajax this time
around so it's a lot of control actions
for that a lot of permissions in the
system because we're very very granular
about what people can do and not do in
the system quite a few caught a lot
fewer ended entities in the system 139
zero value objects because we were using
in any framework and it doesn't support
value objects so nope 18 ohms and in
this case when I pulled it up
about a couple months ago we had about
20 counties in the state of Texas
deployed with a prosecution system and
20 happy counties and that was probably
the most important part so if every
member is this picture this this one
hour on the internet JavaScript the good
parts versus JavaScript the definitive
guide it's like aha that's you know this
is actually the good part it's just that
little little sliver there well I guess
that's growing now with like es6 right
so and I had a similar thing with
domain-driven design have you tried to
encapsulate all the good parts out of
the DD book and try to build your own
book for it it turns out that's actually
just the microservices book so you want
to learn what the good parts of ddd are
I would say just skip this book and go
straight to this one so thank you very
much if you want more information about
this you can find it on my blog or on my
github otherwise thank you for coming
and have a great rest of the conference
[Applause]